so as a stand-up who's appeared on other
late night shows it is a huge thrill and
an honor to have tonight our first
stand-up comic guest he is a writer on
the fantastic brooklyn nine-nine and one
of my personal favorites let's go nuts
for my friend gabe leadman everybody
gabe leaving
what's up everybody
hi
i am so happy to be here a little bit
about me
i'm coming up on my one year anniversary
of moving to l.a
i have lived here for almost a year
i love it here this is such a great town
um my one complaint about la would be
that the weed here is
way too strong
categorically
too
strong and i know there's a lot of pride
on the west coast about how strong the
weed is but you guys
weed is a very innocent drug
and you should be able to smoke it by
the garbage bag full and feel great
here you cannot do that i'll give you an
example on the east coast my favorite
thing to do in the entire world was to
smoke weed and watch intervention at the
exact same time
it's not an option here you cannot do
that here because
it's funny for like one second because
it's like
lol like
whose hands are my hands or whatever
and then instantly it becomes so dark
and so
real
and you're just like oh like
drugs are real
and
they are a real part of my life
um
i guess i'm gonna walk into the sea
which is a dangerous thought here
because it's right there
thank god they finally just canceled
that show intervention it's a great show
don't get me wrong it's a perfect show i
bet they just canceled it because they
couldn't trick anyone into signing up
for it anymore
it was like
at its heart intervention that's a prank
show right
like
it's just a prank show and it's like not
even a creative prank show it's the same
prank every week and they spell it out
on the screen
gabe thinks he's in a documentary about
drug addiction
what he doesn't know is he will soon
face an intervention same prank every
week which means they were just calling
people up and being like do you want to
do drugs on a e
and people were like yeah
wait
is this intervention
then they were like click because it was
in this day and age a good drug addict
should be expecting an intervention
absolutely everywhere they go
right that's why i don't go to brunch
with my friends anymore
because i need my drug to stay chill and
crazy at the same time you guys
and my friends get it they really do my
friends get it they know me really well
they know me almost as well as netflix
does
if that makes sense
netflix knows me so
crazy well
uh i don't know if they like me but they
definitely know
me uh you guys
it is so
spooky when netflix figures out that
you're gay
uh
because you don't tell them that like
it's not like facebook where you sign up
and you're like hello i'm gabriel i'm
from philadelphia and i like to suck on
whatever
right
and then from then on the right hand
third of your screen is just always like
tank tops tank tops for sale
tank top vacation one dollar just for
you gabriel like
you don't tell netflix anything about
yourself they just figure you out over
time using some like judgment algorithm
behind the screen that's just like oh
you watched that huh
kind of thought so or whatever
and i remember the exact moment i knew
that they knew that i was gay i was
logging on to update my queue or
whatever and there it was on the screen
dear gabriel
based on your five-star review of 13
going on 30.
come on gabe
we think
you might really enjoy the entire
jonathan taylor thomas library
and it's like yeah
i probably love it but why don't you
watch your
tone
website and now it's a much more complex
website and their judgment is that much
more complex itself now it's in the form
of these long
made-up genres that i guess are about me
or whatever
that are like top 10 for gabriel
non-cerebral thrillers
that
take place during the day
or like costume comedies
starring only women
and one little fat boy
tom hanks takes the longest piss in it
and it's just like that's not a genre
anymore
you're only describing a league of their
own
that's my time i'm gabe thank you
dave leaving everybody